Zum Beispiel Cyber-Attacken.
Viele werden sich daran gewöhnen. Deshalb haben wir alle Hände voll zu tun. Was noch vor kurzem Zukunftsvision war, ist heute in Deutschland alltäglich und aus dem Leben der Menschen nicht mehr wegzudenken. Jeder kann an nahe zu jedem Ort elektronisch kommunizieren, Informationen abrufen, sowie Produkte und Dienstleistungen im Internet kaufen und sich online fortbilden. Die Menschen leben zunehmend in einer digital vernetzten Welt, am Arbeitsplatz, in der Schule oder Universität und ihren eigenen.
Das ist manchmal auch Hartpolitik.
Du hast das doch prima gemacht.
Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich bin jetzt übrigens wieder da. Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Ach. Wir sind nicht mehr in der Metaebene.
Wir sind nicht mehr in der Metaebene. Wir sind in der Metaebene. Logbuch Netzpolitik, die 150. Jubiläums Strahlermann-Ausgabe, live vom Chaos Communication Camp. Wir sehen euch zwar nicht, aber wir begrüßen euch einfach mal. Hallo, schön, dass ihr da seid!
Und ja, vielen, vielen Dank Arne und Fiona.
Genau, super Applaus hier für unser Cyber-Team.
Arne Bense und Fiona Kragenbürger mit der Cyber-Cyber-Akustik-Version.
So, damit ist der Cyber Warfare offiziell eröffnet. Ich glaub, wir brauchen ein bisschen mehr Licht im Saal, weil so hab ich irgendwie das Gefühl, ich red ins Klo. Hallo.
Ja, ich bin, ich seh da keinen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Ich seh da sonst auch keinen.
Ja, aber dann ist da ja auch keiner.
Das denkst du.
Ja, das will ich mir eigentlich immer ganz, das will ich mir immer ein, das äh...
Das ist komisch, oder?
Ja, jetzt ist das aber, also wir brauchen echt ein bisschen mehr Licht, weil jetzt ist das gerade wie bei so einer äh... Bei so einer Comedy, bei so einer schlechten Comedy. Weißt du, wo du bei denen dann immer so lacher... Weißt du, da ist eigentlich keiner. Stimmt.
Das ist gut, könnte ich den auch auf mein Soundboard drauf machen, irgendwie. Weil, wenn die Sendung dann nicht lustig ist, dann kann man das zumindest so simulieren. Ah, wir kriegen eine erste Vorstellung davon, was hier los ist. Naja, auf jeden Fall haben wir es jetzt irgendwie geschafft, 150 Sendungen zusammen zu kratzen. Ich finde das ziemlich bemerkenswert. Ich denke, wir können uns jetzt offiziell Podcast nennen.
Wir können dann auch mal die Beschreibung anpassen.
Welche?
Da, wo drin steht, wir würden unaufgeregt über das Geschehen berichten.
Unaufgeregt? Was waren die Zeiten? Ja, Cyber. Der Cyber, der hat uns irgendwie total überrollt und alles geht nur noch um Cyber. Was ist da überhaupt passiert? Also ich meine, das war doch mal, was war denn das überhaupt mal für ein Wort? Wer hat denn das verbrochen überhaupt?
War das nicht dieser Lanier oder was?
Nee, ich glaube, das war bestimmt irgendein Science Fiction Autor, der die Zukunft vorher gesehen hat. Aber ich denke, wenn er gewusst hätte, was dann später daraus geworden ist, dann hätte er sein lassen.
Hätte sein lassen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde, wenn du Cyber googles, da gibt es ja interessante Forschungen dazu, welche Farben dann kommen. Also es gibt bei Cyber kommen andere Farben als bei Hacker oder sowas. Und es gibt eine Cyber-Jugendkultur.
Ach, ist das die da jetzt da vorne oder welche?
Nee, die haben eher bunte Haare und...
Cyber?
Die sehen auch ganz komisch aus. Echt? Das könnt ihr nicht sagen. Das ist Nina Hagen.
Nina Hagen.
Das ist Nina Hagen. Ja, wir sind gut vorbereitet.
Wir wollten eigentlich über Cyber reden, aber jetzt sind wir auch vollkommen sprachlos. Auf jeden Fall wird es ein bisschen Zeit, mal so ein bisschen zurückzublicken, aber wir wollen jetzt hier nicht so einen langweiligen Geschichtspodcast machen.
Deswegen fangen wir mit den Erata an.
Aber ich meine, was ist denn passiert? Haben wir Erata?
Ja, wir haben Erata.
Hast du was falsch gemacht?
Ja, mehrere Sendungen lang. Wir haben mehrere Sendungen behauptet, dass die USA Deutschland verbieten würden, die Selektoren rauszugeben. Wirklich? Hat man uns so gesagt? Nee, stellt sich raus, war gar nicht so.
Ach.
Hab ich heute gelesen. Jetzt steht da was anderes in der Zeitung.
Und was steht da jetzt?
NSA-Skandal. USA hat nichts gegen Herausgabe der NSA-Selektorenliste.
Und warum nicht?
Weiß ich nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich nur 5% von dem, was sie wirklich abgehört haben.
Von wem kommt diese Information?
Zeit oder so habe ich das jetzt abgeschrieben.
Zeit. Also nicht von der NSA. Haben die irgendwie eine Pressebeteiligung rausgegeben oder was? Woher wissen die das?
Na, die haben irgendeinen gefragt.
Ah. Und wen?
Ich habe dir gesagt, du sollst nicht so Fragen stellen, wenn die IT-Systeme runtergefahren sind.
Aber wer hat denn nochmal behauptet, dass die USA dagegen gewesen wären?
Na ja, wer auch immer diesen ehemaligen Verfassungsrichter da jetzt hingesetzt hat, ins BND-Gebäude, um die Selektorenliste zu lesen. Die haben sich ja irgendwann mal was dabei gedacht. Das wäre ja vielleicht Landesverrat gewesen, wenn man jetzt die Selektorenliste quasi...
Liest der eigentlich noch? Liest der noch? Na der Verfassungsrichter. Wie hieß der Vogel noch gleich?
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der schon fertig ist.
Ich meine, ich habe immer noch nicht so eine Selektorenliste gelesen. Ich stelle mir ja vor, dass es so spannend ist, als würde man sich SQL-Code durchlesen. Ich stelle mir mal vor, du bist Verfassungsrichter und dann wirst du in so eine Burg eingesperrt und musst irgendwie zwei Monate lang, während wir hier ein Camp feiern, oder wie in Belebad und einen Zug durch die Gegend fahren, musst du den ganzen Tag SQL-Statements lesen. Da weißt du doch nicht mal, was das ist.
Der darf ja auch nachher nichts darüber erzählen. Das heißt, was der da jetzt macht, will ich gar nicht wissen. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er da jetzt sitzt und das alles liest, wenn er weiß, ich bin der einzige Mensch, der nachher sagen könnte, was ich will. Keiner kann es kontrollieren. Und ich darf noch nicht mal was sagen.
Das ist geil, oder?
Der surft im Internet. Und als er die Meldung bei Heise gelesen hat, hat er sich gedacht, Scheiße, gleich holen die mich hier wieder raus.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Bundestag los?
Ja, wollten Computer ausmachen, lassen aber doch erstmal an.
Warum?
Ich glaube, die brauchen die. Ich glaube, die brauchen die.
Wieso? Zum Surfen. Ich glaube schon. Aber wieso, die wollten die doch alle ausschalten, weil das Hacker-Camp ist und weil sie dann irgendwie Angst haben, dass sie kaputt gemacht werden.
Die wollten die ausschalten, weil die seit Monaten diese Trojaner-Infektion haben und derer wahrscheinlich noch nicht so ganz hergeworden sind.
Und jetzt haben sie irgendwie eine E-Mail bekommen, dass Trojaner...
Klicken sie bitte hier.
Wenn man die lange laufen lässt.
Scheiden sie diesen Computer nicht aus.
Nee, dass man da einfach auch eine Menge Geld verdienen kann, wenn man die laufen lässt. Da kam so eine Mail, da stand das drin. Und damit kriegen sie dann die Kosten auch wieder rein.
Ich stelle mir eher so was vor, so öffnen sie die teure Rechnung im Anhang dieser E-Mail. Und dann kommt so ein Fenster, bong, oder wie macht Wunders dann?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber ich meine, warum schalten sie denn jetzt nicht ab? Entschuldigung, ich sollte die Sachen fragen. Letztes Mal hast du hier noch links reingetan, wenn du sowas...
Ja, da war auch nicht Camp. Bundestag verschiebt Abschaltungen des IT-Systems. Wollten wir das noch ausmachen? Aber es könnte eine mögliche Sondersitzung des Parlaments zu neuen Griechenland-Hilfen stattfinden. Und da muss natürlich sichergestellt werden, dass die Amerikaner die Verhandlungsposition des Bundestags kennen. Und deswegen können jetzt die Computer noch nicht ausmachen.
Okay, also die Griechen sind schuld sozusagen. Noch lauter?
Noch lauter?
Wir können das nicht regeln. Wir sind nicht in der Mitter-Ebene.
Aber ich meine, es ist ja erst seit Mitte Mai bekannt, dass diese Computer trojanisiert sind.
Ja, ist ja noch Zeit eigentlich. Wann geht eigentlich die nächste Saison los?
Also Tim, bei Computerviren ist das ja so wie bei kleineren Erkältungen oder so. Was von alleine kommt, das geht auch von alleine wieder. Und so ein halbes Jahr...
Ich habe auch gehört, dass die Systeme dann so ein Immunsystem aufbauen mit der Zeit.
Du musst einfach nur ein Immunsystem installieren.
Du musst das einfach nur lang genug laufen lassen.
So, aber jetzt müssen alle, dass wir diese Witze immer nur machen, wenn wir nicht vorbereitet sind.
Ja, in Berlin müssen sie ja auch irgendwie alles ausschalten, weil da geht irgendwie auch nichts mehr im Abgeordnetenhaus. Aber das hat andere Gründe, weil sie dann irgendwie immer noch die alten Windows-Versionen fahren, die noch nicht supportet sind. Das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Ja, wir könnten nochmal mehr über den Cyber reden oder wir könnten ja uns, wenn wir schon nicht vorbereitet sind, hoffen, dass jemand anderes es ist.
Ja, ich meine, wir könnten nochmal kurz über Cyber reden. Oder wollen wir nachher nochmal mit Cyber reden? Wir reden nachher nochmal über Cyber. Aber irgendwie...
Also Andre hat gesagt, er kommt nicht, wenn wir über Cyber reden.
Wenn wir vorher über Cyber reden oder wenn wir mit ihm über Cyber reden?
Andre, kannst du das nochmal kurz sagen? Gar nicht? Ach, der ist dahinten.
Das ist der mit dem roten Hut. Das ist ja so das neue Ding jetzt. Also man muss ja jetzt, wenn man als Internet-Experte erkannt werden will, braucht man irgendwas Rotes auf dem Kopf.
Ich habe auch was Rotes hier die ganze Zeit auf dem Kopf. Habe ich aber nicht mitgenommen, weil es viel zu dämlich aussieht. Was denn?
Ein Hut. Ein Hut, du hast auch ein Hut. Ein Hut ist jetzt schon durch.
Ja, deswegen habe ich den doch jetzt wieder abgemacht.
Du musst ja was anderes einfallen lassen. Ich weiß nicht, was setzt man sich eigentlich sonst noch alles auf?
Landesverrats-Shirts sind gerade in Mode.
Ah ja, das ist auch sehr hübsch. Na gut, dann lassen wir das mit dem Cyber raus und kommen zu unserem nächsten Thema. Und unser nächstes Thema ist unser nächster Gast.
Genau.
Und da bitten wir dann mal auf die Bühne. Die Julia. Ein Applaus für Julia Reda.
Unser erster Überraschungsgast, der es vorher gespoilert hat, über Twitter.
Ja Mensch, ihr müsst mich besser informieren hier, was meine Aufgabe ist. Also ich bin eh nicht gut vorbereitet, wie man sieht.
Ich glaub du bist wirklich super vorbereitet, weil du weißt ja sowieso alles.
Also einiges, das meiste. Ungefähr ein 751. All dessen, was man in Europa wissen kann.
Ein 751?
Ja, das sind die Abgeordneten im Parlament und gemeinsam sind wir natürlich unschlagbar.
Ah, verstehe.
Den Eindruck hatten wir bei Logbuch Netzpolitik auch.
Also, sollte dich noch jemand nicht kennen, wollen wir dich vielleicht noch mal kurz vorstellen. Du bist ja schon länger politisch aktiv. Das kann ich jetzt nicht genau benennen. Wann hast du so losgelegt?
Ein Weilchen. Also ich war 2003, glaube ich, bei der SPD eingetreten. Und dann irgendwann hielt ich das für keine so gute Idee mehr und bin dann in die Piratenpartei eingetreten. Also das Urteil überlasse ich jetzt den Zuhörenden. Ich bin da immer noch.
Du hast ja auch viel gemacht. Du hast, oh je, jetzt mir der Name entfallen. Wie heißt eure Veranstaltung in Kassel, die ihr immer gemacht habt?
Die Open Mind hab ich damals gegründet, 2010, mit dem Herrn Urbach und einigen anderen sehr netten Leuten und die wird auch nach wie vor betrieben jedes Jahr. Es ist eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung. Das nächste Mal, ich glaube am 13. September.
Ich fand die Atmosphäre sehr angenehm. Also es war einfach sehr, weiß nicht, was darf ich sagen, kuschelig. Es war einfach sehr intensiv. Das ist vielleicht das Wort, das ich gesucht habe.
Ja, es ist eine relativ kompakte Veranstaltung mit so 100, 120 Leuten. Und ursprünglich fing es mal an, dass einige Leute dachten, wir brauchen irgendwas zu netzpolitischen Themen. Jetzt geht es irgendwie um Hausbesetzung dieses Jahr, aber ist super.
Dann hast du dich zur Wahl gestellt und bist jetzt auch piratenintern gewählt worden, nämlich als Spitzenkandidatin bei der Europawahl. Und dann wäre wahrscheinlich gar nichts weiter passiert, hätte dir das Verfassungsgericht nicht Schützenhilfe geleistet.
Ja, genau. Das war ja gewisserweise auch absehbar, dass diese 3-Prozent-Hürde zur Europawahl nicht bestehen bleiben würde. Also da haben ja zum Beispiel die netten Leute von Frag den Staat entsprechende Anfragen gestellt, die eigentlich gezeigt haben, dass die Regierung wusste, dass dieses Gesetz verfassungswidrig sein würde, als sie es eingeführt haben. Dementsprechend war ich dann auch nicht so überrascht, als die 3-Prozent-Hürde gekippt wurde. Hat mir aber natürlich den Einzug ins Europaparlament sehr erleichtert.
Sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern, was damit auf sich hat? Wir reden ja von der Prozentklausel für die Europawahl, die wir ja auch von der Bundestagswahl kennen, die aber jetzt auf Europaebene abgeschafft wurde.
Genau, die Idee ist die, wir haben gewisse Wahlgrundsätze, zum Beispiel die Wahlrechtsgleichheit, und wenn die eingeschränkt wird, muss es dafür einen triftigen Grund geben. Beim Bundestag sagt das Verfassungsgericht, das kann man vertreten, weil die Regierung unmittelbar von dieser Parlamentsmehrheit gestützt wird. Im Europaparlament wird zwar die Kommission vom Parlament einmal bestätigt, aber agiert ansonsten unabhängig. Also die macht Gesetzesvorschläge zwar, aber das Europaparlament, wenn das jetzt die Kommission nicht mehr unmittelbar unterstützt, dann entsteht dadurch kein Schaden. Und deshalb darf es auch keine Einschränkung der Wahlrechtsgleichheit durch eine Klausel geben.
Und die Regel besagt, du brauchst 3% der Stimmen, um überhaupt mit deiner Liste dann einziehen zu können. Oder was genau hat die Regel besagt?
Also ursprünglich gab es die 5-%-Hürde, genauso wie bei der Bundestagswahl. Die wurde dann für verfassungswidrig erklärt. Und kurz vor der Sommerpause hat dann eben die Regierung ein neues Gesetz eingeführt, bzw. vorgelegt für eine 3-%-Hürde. Und überraschenderweise wurde die eben auch für verfassungswidrig erklärt. Das hat zu dem lustigen Effekt geführt, dass wir jetzt ein Wahlsystem haben, bei dem man bei 0,6% seinen ersten Sitz bekommt, bei 1,6% ungefähr den zweiten. Also das heißt, gerade einen Sitz zu bekommen, ist inzwischen extrem leicht. Ich kann das nur empfehlen, irgendwie eine Partei zu gründen und ins Europaparlament einzuziehen. Die Partei hat das sehr erfolgreich auch gemacht.
Ja, du hast da ja so illustre Kollegen sozusagen angesammelt, neben Herrn Sonneborn und dem Nazi.
Also es gibt die Tierschutzpartei, die Familienpartei, die Freien Wähler, die ÖDP, eine ganze Reihe von kleineren Parteien, die jetzt vertreten sind. Es ist aber insofern nicht ungewöhnlich, dass es natürlich auch andere Länder gibt, die wesentlich weniger Sitze haben, von denen es dann auch Parteien gibt, die nur eine Abgeordnete im Europaparlament haben. Das stört jetzt den Betrieb im Parlament eher weniger, weil wir uns natürlich dann auch im Europaparlament in Fraktionen organisieren. Also ich bin in der Fraktion Grüne Eva. Da sind einerseits die diversen grünen Parteien drin, aber eben auch einige Regionalparteien, also zum Beispiel die SNP aus Schottland oder katalonische Regionalisten, die irgendwie eher links orientiert sind, die sind eben auch in dieser Fraktion mit drin.
Die SNP ist bei den Grünen?
Die SNP ist in der Grüne Eva-Fraktion, ja. Ich bin auch Teil von deren Vorstand, das ist eine sehr interessante Konstruktion. Meistens wird da aber auch jetzt von nationaler Ebene relativ wenig nachgefragt. Also die Piratenpartei, die Grünen, die ÖDP aus Deutschland sind in der gleichen Fraktion und das führt in den allerwenigsten Fällen tatsächlich irgendwie zu Konflikten. Also Fraktion braucht man allein schon dafür, um seine Arbeit zu organisieren. Also es ist tatsächlich relativ pragmatisch insofern, dass bei den meisten Fragen die Grünen-Fraktion mir folgt, wenn es ums Urheberrecht geht und ich schaue mir aber dann auch bestimmte Fragen zur Umweltpolitik nicht so genau an, sondern kann mich auch darauf verlassen, dass die sich das anschauen. Es ist eine Frage der Arbeitsteilung und halt der Organisation im Parlament.
Wie war denn das jetzt für dich in das EU-Parlament reinzukommen? Ich meine, sagen wir mal so, wie sehr hast du dich vorher schon damit beschäftigt und was war dann vielleicht noch überraschend und anders, als du dir das gedacht hast?
Also ich kam auf die Idee in meinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn irgendwie zwei Jahre vor der Wahl, als es die großen Proteste gegen das Akteabkommen gab. Also auch damals habe ich mich irgendwie mit Urheberrechtsfragen beschäftigt. Und ich habe damals halt in Frankfurt die Proteste mit organisiert und konnte dann im Europaparlament bei einer von den schwedischen Piraten ein Praktikum machen. Und ja, da habe ich halt gesehen, hey, offensichtlich ist das ein Parlament, wo man auch irgendwie durch direkte Beteiligung noch Entscheidungen verändern kann. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von neuen Kompetenzen, die das Parlament hat, die vielleicht auch noch nicht überall so im Bewusstsein angekommen sind. Und das führt zwar auf der einen Seite leider dazu, dass es nicht so viel direkte Öffentlichkeit gibt für das, was im Parlament passiert. Aber die Kehrseite, und das ist auch das Spannende, weil ich dann halt festgestellt habe, als ich ins Parlament eingezogen bin, dass ich als einzelne Abgeordnete dort eigentlich unglaublich viel bewegen kann, weil mir eine ganze Menge von Möglichkeiten offen stehen, die man jetzt vielleicht im Bundestag so nicht hätte. Also mir kommt eine ganze Menge von Dingen komisch vor. Es ist letzten Endes, also die erste Sache, die komisch war, ich bin da reingekommen, das Parlament, also erstmal hat der konservative Kommissionspräsident Jean-Claude Juncker gesagt, dass mit dem Urheberrecht was nicht stimmt und dass das irgendwie der europäischen Wirtschaft im Wege steht. Das fand ich schon mal eine sehr bemerkenswerte Aussage von einem konservativen Kommissionspräsidenten, konservativen Politiker überhaupt. Und dann hat das Parlament entschieden, jetzt sich mit dem Urheberrecht auseinanderzusetzen und hat mir die Aufgabe gegeben, dazu einen Bericht vorzulegen. Das fand ich auch erst mal überraschend. Ich habe die Hand gehoben, als es darum ging, wer sich um diesen Bericht kümmern muss. Also man muss die Arbeitsweise im Parlament kennen. Es gibt immer für jedes Gesetzgebungsverfahren, für jeden Bericht, das das Parlament macht, eine verantwortliche Person, die den ersten Entwurf schreibt, die die ganzen Verhandlungen führt und so weiter. Also zum Beispiel die Berichterstatter. Also beim, ich weiß nicht, Datenschutzverordnung, kennt man vielleicht Jan Philipp Albrecht, der das macht. Und darum wird sich normalerweise gekloppt. Also zumindest bei Berichten, die eine gewisse Bedeutung haben. Im Zweifelsfall bekommt das die größte Fraktion, weil die eben sagen kann, wir haben irgendwie in unserem Punktesystem noch so viele Punkte übrig, wir wollen das jetzt unbedingt haben. In dem Fall war das überhaupt nicht so. Ich habe gesagt, ich möchte das gerne machen. Und die anderen Fraktionen haben gesagt, ja wunderbar.
Haben die alle das Memo nicht bekommen, dass sie eine Piratenpartei-Vertreterin ans Urheberrecht lassen? Das finde ich ja super, aber die schlafen doch da.
Halt ich für unwahrscheinlich, weil durchaus einige Lobby-Organisationen, wie zum Beispiel der beliebte CC, der Composers Club, der früher CTC hieß, zum Beispiel Abgeordnete angeschrieben hat und gesagt hat hier, dass ihr der Piratin könnte das doch nicht geben, hat allerdings nicht zu dem gewünschten Erfolg geführt.
Ja, aber was hat denn dann überhaupt dazu geführt? Hat sich jetzt sonst jemand gemeldet?
Also ich kann nur darüber spekulieren, warum sie mir diese Rolle gegeben haben. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die ein oder anderen dachten, dass ich dort komplett auf Granit beißen würde, dass ich halt irgendwie den Piraten-zehn-Punkte-Plan zur Abschaffung des Urheberrechts vorlegen würde oder so, und dass sie das in Ruhe ablehnen können. Und dann wäre ich für die nächsten vier Jahre kaltgestellt, das kann sein. Es kann aber auch sein, dass die einfach irgendwie andere Themen zu dem Zeitpunkt wichtiger fanden. Also die Sozialdemokraten haben dann stattdessen den Bericht bekommen über geografischen Kennzeichnungsschutz. Also da geht es dann um die Frage, ob ich ein Messer herstellen darf in Offenbach und das Meißner Messer nennen darf. Das ist auch sehr interessant.
Wie viele Berichterstatter-Posten gibt es da so zu vergeben im Schnitt?
Also man muss erstmal grundsätzlich unterscheiden zwischen tatsächlichen Gesetzgebungsverfahren und diesen Berichten. Also Berichte darf jeder Ausschuss im Parlament parallel sechs Stück bearbeiten. Und es gibt irgendwie so um die 20 Ausschüsse, also das sind schon eine ganze Menge. Und daneben gibt es dann die Gesetzgebungsverfahren, die eigentlich formal wichtiger sind. Also das, was ich gemacht habe, ist eben ein Bericht über das bestehende UE-Berecht. Und der ist letzten Endes so wichtig, wie die Leute ihn nehmen. Also das ist kein Gesetz, aber dadurch, dass sich alle furchtbar darüber aufgeregt haben, erstens, dass eine Pirate in diesem Bericht schreibt und dann darüber, was dort drin stand, hat er jetzt eben doch einen größeren Einfluss auf die Debatte bekommen.
Und das ist dann so die Formulierung der Position des Parlaments?
Genau, also die Kommission hat halt von Anfang an angekündigt, dass sie an das Urheberrecht jetzt ran wollen. Hat sich dann leider ein bisschen ins Knie geschossen, ausgerechnet Günther Oettinger damit zu beauftragen, da den Entwurf vorzulegen. Also der ist dann quasi mein Gegenpol in der Kommission. Und wir wissen jetzt eben von Parlamentsseite, dass es Ende des Jahres ein neues Urheberrechtsgesetz geben soll. Also dass die Kommission uns vorlegt und wir müssen das dann verabschieden. Und damit die Kommission dort halt nicht einfach irgendwas vorschlägt, hat das Parlament sich eben vorher schon in diesem Bericht mit dem bestehenden Urheberrecht auseinandergesetzt und gesagt, okay, hier sind die Probleme.
Das heißt, der wird den jetzt, also okay Günther, es ist schwer vorher zu sagen, was Günther Oettinger tut, wenn man ihm etwas gibt.
Das Leistungsschutzrecht wahrscheinlich.
Also lesen wird das schon mal nicht. Und dann wird er, inwiefern ist er jetzt daran gebunden? Also heißt das im Prinzip, du hast jetzt einen Bericht geschrieben. Bericht ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen irreführendes Wort, oder? Also das kommt ja eigentlich von Rapport, oder?
Ja, also eigentlich das, was wir jetzt haben, ist eine Resolution des Europäischen Parlaments. Also das ist ein Beschluss, der aber eben seinerseits kein Gesetz ist. Günther Oettinger muss sich an den nicht halten. Allerdings, wenn er jetzt das Gegenteil von dem vorschlägt, was das Parlament sagt, dann weiß er eigentlich schon vorher, dass das Parlament das ablehnen wird. Also die Kommissionen sind die einzigen, die eben neue Gesetze vorlegen dürfen, neue Initiativen starten. Das Parlament muss dem aber zustimmen letzten Endes und kann es auch verändern. Also zum Beispiel hatte Oettinger immer mal wieder in Interviews gesagt, also ein europäisches Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger wäre eine super Sache, das müssen wir jetzt unbedingt einführen. Und da hat das Parlament jetzt eben zweimal auf meine Initiative hingesagt, das ist absoluter Quatsch, hat eigentlich Google nur genützt und allen anderen geschadet und das wollen wir nicht haben. Wenn er es jetzt trotzdem vorschlägt, dann können wir ihn daran nicht hindern. Ein drittes Mal ablehnen, können wir es schon.
Hast du schon mal mit ihm so Kontakt gehabt, also gesprochen?
Ja, sicher. Also wir haben uns auch schon getroffen. Sein Team hat sogar davon getwittert und es war alles ganz öffentlich und juvial.
Ich meine, er kann dir doch jetzt nichts zu sagen. Der Mann muss doch noch ihr Gesetz dann verabschieden. Ach nee, verabschieden, schreiben und ihr verabschiedet das dann.
Genau so läuft das ja. Also er macht den ersten Aufschlag, wir dürfen dann seinen Vorschlag verändern und insofern kann er halt in gewisser Weise so den Rahmen bestimmen. Also wie viel, also wie weit er jetzt ans Urheberrecht rangeht. Also im Moment haben wir ja 28 verschiedene nationale Urheberrechte und nur so ein paar Grundregeln, die überhaupt auf europäischer Ebene geregelt sind. Er könnte jetzt sich hinstellen und ein europäisches Urheberrecht vorschlagen, das im Prinzip alles, was wir im Moment haben, ersetzen würde. Er kann aber auch irgendwie eine Mini-Reform vorschlagen und das hat natürlich einen Einfluss darauf, inwieweit wir als Parlament diesen Vorschlag dann verändern können.
Für deinen Bericht hast du sehr, sehr viel Lob bekommen von den Leuten, denen ich eine qualifizierte Beurteilung eines solchen Berichtes zutraue. Wie viel Arbeit war das eigentlich? Also wie viel hast du da jetzt reingesteckt? Für mich klingt das so überraschend oder auch so ein bisschen schockierend zu sehen, du hast da sicherlich viel Arbeit reingesteckt, hast dir viele Gedanken darüber gemacht und jetzt musst du das so jemandem wie Günther Oettinger geben und der wird dann halt irgendwie etwas daraus machen, aber es ist für dich jetzt ungewiss. Da ist ja sicherlich jetzt sehr viel Herzblut da drin und ich meine, wie stehst du dem jetzt gegenüber? Was erwartest du oder wie bewertest du das, dass du, also wie damit jetzt weiter verfahren wird? Was du gerade schon sagt, da kann jetzt alles draus werden oder nichts. Wie empfindest du das als Wertschätzung deines, strukturelle Wertschätzung deines Arbeitsaufwandes?
Also ich finde das eigentlich eine ganz komfortable Situation. Ich glaube nicht, dass dieser Bericht irgendwie in der Schublade verschwinden wird, eben weil er solche Wellen gemacht hat. Also ich glaube, die wenigsten Berichte, die eben keine Gesetze sind von der EU, bekommen diese Art von medialer Aufmerksamkeit. Und letzten Endes hängt es halt irgendwie auch an der kritischen Öffentlichkeit, ob wir alles vergessen, was wir da jetzt besprochen haben. Also zum Beispiel war groß in den Medien die Panoramafreiheit. Das hat meine lieben Kollegen im Rechtsausschuss der Meinung waren, wenn man irgendwie Fotos von öffentlichen Gebäuden im Internet veröffentlicht und damit in irgendeiner Form Geld verdient, weil man Werbebanner hat oder so, dass man dann Architekten dafür bezahlen muss, weil das Gebäude ist ja deren geistige Leistung und das hat also, wenn so ein schlechter Vorschlag auf dem Tisch liegt, dann ist auch die Öffentlichkeit da, die sagt, das ist völliger Unsinn und die haben dann das Parlament an der Stelle auch umgestimmt. Was wir jetzt halt natürlich machen müssen, ist anerkennen, dass das dieser schwachsinnige Vorschlag in fünf europäischen Ländern heute Realität ist und dass wir das vielleicht mal ändern sollten. Also Panoramafreiheit gibt es überhaupt nicht in Frankreich, in Italien, Luxemburg, Belgien, glaube ich, und dann gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Ländern, wo sie eingeschränkt ist, in Deutschland übrigens auch. Also man könnte Probleme kriegen, wenn man mit Drohnen Fotos macht. Da gab es zum Beispiel mal einen Fall, also in Deutschland darf man halt nur Fotos von öffentlichen Gebäuden verwenden, wenn man sie selber von öffentlichem Grund ausgeschossen hat, und ein deutsches Unternehmen hat mal Kunstdrucke vom Hundertwasserhaus in Wien in Deutschland verkauft, woraufhin dann die Erben von Hundertwasser geklagt haben, weil dieses Foto aus einer Privatwohnung von der anderen Straßenseite aufgenommen wurde. Leider ist das in Österreich völlig legal. Also die österreichische Panoramafreiheit sagt, das Gebäude muss öffentlich sein, wo der Fotograf ist, ist egal. In Deutschland ist das nicht so. Also das ist die sogenannte Territorialität des Urheberrechts, die eben besagt. Das Urheberrecht gilt immer genau in dem Land, wo ein Werk verbreitet wird. Und es ist völlig egal, ob das legal in einem anderen Land erstellt wurde oder nicht. Und dieses Prinzip wendet man dann aufs Internet an, was zu offensichtlichen Problemen führt.
Wie ist das? War denn das jetzt eigentlich nur so ein Unfall, dass das da so reingeschrieben wurde und die wussten gar nicht so richtig, was sie meinen? Und haben da gar nicht drüber nachgedacht und dann regen sie auf alle auf und dann so, oh, Entschuldigung, das ist mir wieder nebengegangen. Oder gibt es tatsächlich Leute, die der Meinung sind, man sollte jetzt sozusagen für jedes Foto an Architekten bis ans Lebensende Geld bezahlen?
Also da kommt es immer drauf an, um wen es geht. Also ich als Berichterstatterin habe den ursprünglichen Vorschlag gemacht. Hier, wir weiten die Panoramafreit auf ganz Europa aus. Und wir sollten sowieso die gleichen Regelungen haben, welche Ausnahmen vom Urheberrecht es gibt. Die Person, also der Schattenberichterstatter, das ist quasi mein Gegenstück in den anderen Fraktionen, von der liberalen Fraktion, der hat mit voller Absicht eben diesen Änderungsantrag eingereicht. Was ganz witzig ist, wenn man bedenkt, dass der halt zum Beispiel die deutsche FDP dort mitvertritt, die danach eine große Kampagne gemacht hat, mein Panorama, meine Freiheit, und sich irgendwie vor dem Fernsehturm fotografiert haben und so. Also bei dem war das sicherlich Absicht, der kommt halt aus Frankreich, der ist der Meinung, französische Architekten werden bezahlt und das ist auch gut so, und das sollte man jetzt auch in anderen Ländern zu handhaben. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in den Fraktionen, die dafür gestimmt haben, unter anderem CDU, SPD, das nicht unbedingt gewollt war, allerdings sind die im Zweifelsfall eben auch ihren Schattenberichterstatterin gefolgt. Und wenn die eben die entsprechende Vorgabe gemacht haben, dann muss man davon ausgehen, dass die meisten Abgeordneten sich das nicht vorher im Detail angeguckt haben, worüber sie da abstimmen. Aber es ist halt absurd, weil genau die Fraktionen, die vorher gesagt haben, also die Sozialdemokraten zum Beispiel, die diesem Antrag zugestimmt haben, danach dann gesagt haben, ja vielleicht ist die Ausweitung der Panoramafreiheit ja doch eine gute Idee und wir haben das ja schon immer vertreten und werden das weiterverfolgen.
Ist ja jetzt auch nicht so das erste Mal bei den Sozialdemokraten.
Ja, also als ich in der SPD war, habe ich das auch schon vertreten, insofern haben sie recht.
Wieso braucht Europa denn ein vereinheitliches Urheberrecht? Also du erzählst immer so wunderschöne, also du hast glaube ich wahrscheinlich so, ich weiß nicht genau wie viele Anekdoten über Kuriositäten des Urheberrechtes du auf dem Kasten hast. Zwei, drei weitere will ich heute Abend noch hören, weil die einfach auch immer witzig sind. Aber wenn wir es jetzt nur vereinheitlichen, dann haben wir wahrscheinlich doch einfach nur überall die gleichen Kuriositäten, oder?
Also das ist eine grundsätzliche Frage, ob wir es irgendwie für möglich halten, sinnvolle demokratische Entscheidungen zu treffen oder nicht. Wenn wir glauben, dass wir das nicht können, dann gilt das für Europa genauso, wie das für Deutschland oder meinetwegen für Berlin gilt. Ich bin jetzt halt in einem Parlament und es wäre blöd dann auf dem Standpunkt zu stehen, dass wir keine sinnvollen Entscheidungen treffen können. Also treffen wir die sinnvollen Entscheidungen doch auf europäischer Ebene. Also ich benutze diese Beispiele, weil das das ganz schön illustriert. Wir haben unterschiedliche Schutzfristen im Urheberrecht, je nach Land. Also die EU hat immer nur vorgegeben, was wir mindestens urheberrechtlich schützen müssen. Also jetzt mal wegen bei einem Buch, 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors. Darüber hinaus können die Länder dann aber Sonderregelungen treffen. Das heißt, der kleine Prinz zum Beispiel von Saint-Exupéry, der 1945 gestorben ist, ist jetzt dieses Jahr gemeinfrei geworden in der EU bis auf Frankreich, weil es ist übrigens Zufall, dass das jetzt schon wieder ein Beispiel aus Frankreich ist. Es ist nicht alles schlimm dort, aber in Frankreich gibt es 30 Jahre extra Urheberrechtsschutz für Kriegshelden. Und Menschen, die für Frankreich in einem Krieg gefallen sind, weil die sind ja unnatürlich frühzeitig abgelebt. Das muss man kompensieren durch eine längere Urheberrechtsfrist. Das bedeutet in der Praxis, ich darf auf meine Website den kleinen Prinz hochladen, weil er ist sehr gemeinfrei. Es sei denn, meine Website richtet sich vornehmlich an ein französisches Publikum. Was ich für ein extrem merkwürdiges Konzept halte. Ich bin auch häufiger auf dieses Problem gestoßen, weil ich mich mit allem, was ich irgendwie im Rahmen meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit veröffentliche, an die gesamte europäische Öffentlichkeit richte. Das heißt, eigentlich müsste ich alle europäischen Urheberrechtsgesetze befolgen. Und es gilt dann jeweils das Restriktivste, aber das wäre ja Schwachsinn. Ja, das könnte ich machen. Damit würde ich mich zumindest vor Klagen schützen. Es ist allerdings nicht so, dass ich irgendwie, also nirgendwo im Urheberrecht steht, dass ich alles blocken muss, was irgendwo anders illegal ist. Sonst würde ja auf der ganzen Welt automatisch das weitgehendste Urheberrechts gelten. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was vor allen Dingen von den großen Studios, Filmstudios, Rechteinhabern eben in ihren Verträgen vorgeschrieben wird. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Disney-Film zeigen will auf meiner Videoplattform, dann sagt Disney mir, du bekommst diese Lizenz exklusiv für ein bestimmtes Land und du musst sicherstellen, dass Leute in anderen Ländern das nicht sehen können. Das widerspricht eigentlich irgendwie dem Grundgedanken der EU. Wir haben eine Dienstleistungsfreiheit und es dürfte eigentlich überhaupt nicht legal sein.
Dann müssen wir den Markt harmonitarisieren.
Also das ist eigentlich so eine Grundidee, dass man halt irgendwie wirtschaftliche Freiheiten hat, sich frei bewegen darf in der EU und halt auch Dienste aus einem anderen Land kaufen. Da haben sich einige meiner Kollegen wirklich auf ganz, ganz komische Positionen versteift, dass sie eben sagten, ganz im Gegenteil, das Geoblocking schützt uns vor einer Übermacht amerikanischer Inhalte. Und wenn wir jetzt kein Geoblocking hätten, dann hätten wir weniger europäische Filme, weil die sich nur finanzieren können, wenn sie eben per Geoblocking verhindern, dass ich den Film in einem anderen Land schon sehen kann, bevor er dort ins Kino geht und so. Und wir haben ja sowieso zu viele amerikanische Inhalte im Fernsehen, und das würde dadurch dann noch verstärkt. Also eine Freundin von mir verglich das, diese Argumentation, also als mit dem digitalen anti-imperialistischen Schutzwall, das fand ich ganz schön. Also, oder eine Kollegin hat sich auch in einer Ausschusssitzung, die war von der CDU hingestellt, und gesagt, ja, ich kann ja auch kein finnisches Brot in Brüssel kaufen. Und deshalb gehe ich nicht zur Kommission und sage, die muss was dagegen tun. Also einen Tag später hatte ich ein finnisches Brot in der Ausschusssitzung dabei. Selbstverständlich kann ich das kaufen. Und das wird auch nicht vom Zoll aufgehalten, wenn ich es mir schicken lasse.
Mit wie vielen Leuten hast du es da zu tun? Es ist im Rechtsausschuss, das Ganze.
Genau, es gibt erst mal sieben Fraktionen, jetzt acht, also die Nazis haben jetzt auch noch eine gegründet. Die haben jeweils eben Schattenberichterstatterin. Das ist so der kleinere Kreis von Leuten, mit denen ich mich auseinandersetzen muss. Der Rechtsausschuss insgesamt hat dann 50 Mitglieder. Und wir hatten da schon einige Auseinandersetzungen, die wirklich merkwürdig waren. Also zum Beispiel hatte ich mal den Vorschlag gemacht, die UN-Sonderberichterstatterin für kulturelle Rechte vor dem Ausschuss sprechen zu lassen, weil die eben ein Bericht zum Urheberrecht veröffentlicht hat, indem sie sich mit den Problemen einerseits von Kulturschaffenden auseinandersetzt, einerseits mit dem Recht auf Zugang zu Kultur. Und ja, also der Kollege von den Liberalen zum Beispiel war dann eben der Meinung, dass sie dort besser nicht sprechen sollte, weil sie halt der Meinung ist, dass das Urheberrecht manchmal auch Einschränkungen braucht, um Kulturschaffende zu schützen und sagte, also die darf dort nur sprechen, wenn es eine Gegenposition gibt, zum Beispiel von jemandem von Verwertungsgesellschaften. Also wir sprechen hier von der UN-Sonderberichterstatterin, die irgendwie für Menschenrechte zuständig ist. Das gehört dann auch zu dem Alltag dort.
Ja, es ist ja wie im Fernsehen, wenn so sonntags die Diskussionsrunden besetzt werden. Wir brauchen da noch eine Gegenposition.
Ja, also alles fair and balanced grundsätzlich.
Und wo willst du jetzt hin oder ich meine, was hältst du jetzt für durchsetzbar? Was hast du so für ein Gefühl bekommen, rein aus der Parlamentsperspektive? Weil die Auseinandersetzung mit Kommissionen ratet ja nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer, aber was denkst du, in welche Richtung du das jetzt geschoben bekommst, beziehungsweise was da so ein Konsens sein könnte in der Gruppe? Was ändert sich, wenn es nach denen und dir und nach denen ging?
Also das Parlament hat meinem Bericht erst mal mit einer überwältigen Mehrheit zugestimmt, irgendwas um die 450 zu 60 Stimmen oder so. Und in diesem Bericht steht unter anderem, dass es europaweite User-Rechte geben muss. Also bisher ist es so, Rechteinhaber haben Rechte, User haben Ausnahmen von diesen Rechten, aber ob die eingeführt werden oder nicht, ist im Prinzip jedem Land einzeln überlassen. Also das geht jetzt noch nicht so weit, wie zu sagen, wir haben europäisches Urheberrecht, aber es sagt zumindest irgendwie so ein paar grundlegende Sachen, die notwendig sind für freie Meinungsäußerung. Zum Beispiel Ausnahmen zu haben vom Urheberrecht für solche Dinge wie Zitate, wie Parodien, da muss es ein Mindeststandard geben, der in der ganzen EU gilt. Das vertritt die Kommission auch und insofern gehe ich davon aus, dass es zumindest eine Teilweise Verpflichtungen gibt für die Mitgliedstaaten eben diese Mindeststandards zu setzen. Außerdem soll es halt einen Schutz gerade von Bildung und Wissenschaft geben. Da gibt es ein paar absurde Auswüchse des Urheberrechts, die einfach dadurch kommen, dass jegliche Form der Kopie eine Erlaubnis bedarf und wir jetzt mit digitaler Technologie die ganze Zeit Kopien anlegen. Beispiel irgendwie mein bekannter Enno, der ein digitales Hörgerät trägt. Der hört im Grunde genommen eine digitale Kopie von analogen Signalen. Und wenn es keine Ausnahmen vom Urheberrecht gäbe, dann würde der jedes Mal, wenn er sich ein Lied anhört, eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begehen, weil da halt eine Kopie stattfindet. Genauso könnte man sich fragen, ob Überwachungskameras da so legal sind. Das ist auch vielleicht ein interessantes Forschungsfeld. Dass daran irgendwie was gemacht wird, ist halt für die Wissenschaft extrem wichtig, weil die halt mit Big Data zunehmend arbeiten und irgendwie, um einen großen Datensatz auswerten zu können, zum Beispiel irgendwie 50.000 medizinische Artikel über das gleiche Genom, um das machen zu können, müssen sie halt eine Kopie von den Werken in der Datenbank anlegen. Und Wissenschaftsverlage sind halt der Meinung, dafür brauchen die eine Lizenz, obwohl sie schon dafür bezahlt haben, diese Sachen irgendwie lesen zu dürfen.
Aber mir gefällt die Perspektive ganz gut, dass man sozusagen Überwachungskameras damit abschaffen kann, indem man die ganze Zeit so Mickey-Maus-Poster so vor sich her trägt. Und sagst du, ja sie dürfen mich nicht bewachen, weil das wäre ja eine Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Könnte funktionieren. Also das ist halt auch das Witzige. Eigentlich wissen alle, dass sich niemand an das Urheberrecht hält und damit wird auch völlig offen argumentiert. Also bei der Auseinandersetzung um die Panoramafreiheit haben die Verwertungsgesellschaften in den Ländern, wo es halt keine Panoramafreiheit gibt, gesagt, ach die Leute auf Facebook müssen sich ja keine Sorgen machen, weil die verfolgen wir ja nicht. Also das letzte Ende ist das Problematische ist, denke ich, auch die Verknüpfung auf der einen Seite von Überwachung der Bevölkerung mit auf der anderen Seite Gesetzen, die von jedem gebrochen werden. Weil das führt halt dazu, dass man diese Gesetze selektiv durchsetzen kann gegen die Person, die einen gerade nervt.
Genau, dann sollte man sie aber so nicht schreiben. Okay, weiterer, also Nutzerrechte als wichtiger Teil deines Berichts?
Wissenschaft, also dass man halt ein paar neue Schranken einführt, zum Beispiel eben für Daxondata-Mining. Noch ein wichtiger Punkt ist der Schutz von gemeinfreien Werken. Also im Moment gibt es keinerlei Definition im Recht davon, was eigentlich mit Werken ist, die keinen Urheberrechtsschutz genießen. Das führt dazu, dass halt zum Beispiel es immer mal wieder Klagen gibt von Museen, die irgendwelche Webseiten abmahnen, die Fotos von Gemälden veröffentlichen, obwohl diese Gemälde halt der Autor längst vor mehr als 70 Jahren gestorben sind und eigentlich jeder das Recht haben sollte, dass diese Werke auch frei verbreitet werden dürfen. Dann argumentieren die Museen teilweise ja, aber da hat ein Angestellter des Museums halt dieses Foto gemacht und das war ja ein großer Aufwand und so und deshalb müsste man dafür zahlen. Also da sagt halt das in meinem Bericht ganz klar, also wenn ein Werk einmal gemeinfrei ist, dann kann man das nicht wieder privatisieren, indem man es digitalisiert. Also die digitale Form von einem gemeinfreien Werk ist auch gemeinfrei und es bleibt so. Also das ist für freie Wissensprojekte denke ich von enorm hoher Bedeutung, weil sonst eben an letzten Endes eine Privatisierung unseres gesamten kulturellen Erbes hat und irgendwelche Firmen, die es sich halt leisten können, diese Digitalisierung vorzunehmen, dann eben die absolute Kontrolle darüber haben, was mit diesen digitalen Versionen von unserer Geschichte letzten Endes passiert.
Haben diese Firmen eine Möglichkeit, dagegen zu lobbyieren? Sind die groß genug oder?
Also das ist immer die Frage, wo die Leute ihre Prioritäten setzen. Also besonders aktiv in Sachen Lobbyismus sind in Brüssel sicherlich die Verwertungsgesellschaften, für die ist das vielleicht nicht die oberste Priorität. Die Wissenschaftsverlage, die vor allen Dingen eben versuchen, solche Dinge wie eine neue Ausnahme für Text-and-Data-Mining zu verhindern und die Rechteinhaber von Filmen und großen Sportveranstaltungen, die vor allen Dingen das Geoblocking erhalten wollen. Ich denke, das Geoblocking ist gerade ein Thema, wo halt im Parlament noch extrem viel Arbeit vor uns liegt und wo ich es für wichtig halte, dass sich da mehr Leute einmischen. Weil ich kann mich erinnern an die Akta-Proteste, da sind die Leute halt wirklich mit Plakaten auf die Straße gegangen, 2012, auf denen drauf stand, dieses Video ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar und wir haben jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Politikerinnen im Europaparlament, die der Meinung sind, das müssen wir so lassen, weil das Geoblocking irgendwie wichtig ist für unsere Kultur und ich finde, das ist was, wogegen wir auf jeden Fall aufstehen müssen.
Aber das heißt so mit dem Filesharing, das hast du uns jetzt erst mal nicht...
Also ich glaube, es ist nicht so sinnvoll, wenn wir versuchen, die ganze Debatte über das Urheberrecht immer auf die Durchsetzung zu lenken. Also in der Filesharing-Debatte geht es ja vor allen Dingen darum, was machen wir mit Urheberrechtsverletzungen? Wie gehen wir gegen die vor? Wie hoch sind die Strafen und so weiter und so fort? Und das Problem ist viel fundamentaler, nämlich, dass unser Urheberrecht absolut kaputt ist, dass wir 28 auf Länder begrenzte Urheberrechte haben, die im Internet überhaupt nicht miteinander verträglich sind und die letzten Endes verhindern, dass wir legal miteinander über Landesgrenzen in der EU kommunizieren können. Und es ist eigentlich die Strategie der Rechteinhaber, die von dieser Situation profitieren, die Debatte immer auf die Rechtsdurchsetzung zu lenken, anstatt wirklich diese fundamentalen Probleme anzugehen. Insofern, also ich glaube, dass die viele der Probleme, die um Filesharing herum diskutiert werden, erst in der Folge davon gelöst werden, dass wir überhaupt erst mal feststellen, dass Urheberrecht muss Grenzen haben und diese Grenzen müssen für die Menschen verständlich sein und müssen von Land zu Land eben auch gleich sein. Und wenn wir an dem Punkt sind, dann können wir denke ich auch wieder über die Durchsetzung reden.
Wie war denn jetzt, also würde mich abschließend noch mal so interessieren, wie war denn jetzt so deine, du hast jetzt viel, du hast ein bisschen berichtet von den Auseinandersetzungen mit den Schattenberichterstattern. Da waren dann sicherlich einige dabei, denen das ganze Thema nicht so viel am Herzen liegt. Einige, die dann vielleicht mal das ein oder andere Thema einstreuen. Wurdest du jetzt auch von den Lobbyisten, die du gerade genannt hast, da irgendwie wurde dir da auch die Tür eingerannt. Also man hört ja spannende Geschichten von Jan-Philipp Albrecht oder so, als er an den Datenschutz rangehen wollte, die Tür eingerannt wurde. Und ging es dir ähnlich? Oder haben die dich am Anfang erst mal gar nicht ernst genommen?
Also es war schon beachtlich irgendwie die Aufmerksamkeit, die ich bekommen habe. Ich glaube, ich hatte so um die 100 Meetings mit Lobbyistinnen, bevor ich den Bericht veröffentlicht habe. Danach haben die dann ihre Aufmerksamkeit auch ein bisschen mehr auf die anderen Fraktionen gelenkt, weil es dann natürlich darum ging, meinen Bericht zu verändern, durch Änderungsanträge, von denen ich auch über 500 bekommen habe, die wir dann irgendwie abgearbeitet haben. Ich habe diese ganzen Anfragen, die ich bekommen habe, veröffentlicht. Und ja, das war insofern auch für mich eine gewisse Kontrolle eben zu sehen, mit wem rede ich da eigentlich, welche Gruppen sind vertreten. Was auch eine ganz wichtige Arbeitsgrundlage war, dass eigentlich die Europäische Kommission schon strukturiert alle Lobbygruppen befragt hatte zum Urheberrecht, bevor die Wahl überhaupt war. Also es gab eine Konsultation zum Urheberrecht, wo auch Leute auf einem der C3s vor ein, zwei Jahren ein Tool gebaut haben, das es irgendwie leuchtenleicht gemacht hat, auf diesen Fragebogen zu antworten. Das hat halt dazu geführt, dass erstmals wirklich irgendwie 10.000 Leute sich daran beteiligt haben. Und die Hälfte davon waren irgendwie Internet-User, der Rest waren halt Verwertungsgesellschaften, Internet-Provider, Urheber und so weiter. Und das hat schon mal so einen Überblick gegeben, was für Lobbygruppen und was für Interessen es eigentlich gibt. Und da hat man gesehen, also dass das, was in Brüssel tatsächlich vor Ort vertreten wird, einfach strukturell anders ist. Es gibt einige Gruppen, die einfach viel mehr Geld und Möglichkeiten haben, Lobbyismus zu betreiben. Und dazu gehören weder die Urheber noch die Nutzer. Die Verwerter, sicherlich auch die Werksmittler zu einem gewissen Grad. Also die Internet-Provider haben durchaus auch ihre Lobbybüros, aber vor allen Dingen eben die Verwertungsgesellschaften und die Verlage, die Rechteinhaber von Filmen und so weiter. Und das sind dann letzten Endes auch die, die den größten Einfluss auf die Debatte nehmen konnten. Aber da, wo sich halt irgendwie Zivilgesellschaft organisiert hat, zum Beispiel die Bibliotheken, die sehr, sehr strukturiert irgendwie erklärt haben, hier, wir versuchen uns an dieses Urheberrecht zu halten, und das ist absolut unmöglich, da hat man dann doch gemerkt, okay, die haben mit ihrem Input an die Abgeordneten dann auch wirklich was erreicht. Zu dem Thema vielleicht noch eine Anekdote. Das hat mir einer von der Nationalbibliothek erzählt. Da hat jemand angerufen und hat gesagt, er hätte gerne irgendwie eine Kopie von so einem Buch, das es nur noch in der Deutschen Nationalbibliothek gibt, also irgendwas Historisches. Das Ding ist am zerfallen, die dürfen das nicht, also die können das nicht ohne Weiteres verschicken. Und dieser Typ war halt in einer anderen Stadt. Was sie also machen durften, war, also sie durften keine Kopie von dem Buch machen und ihm das zuschicken, weil das hätte möglicherweise irgendwie das Urheberrecht verletzt. Was sie machen durften, war, sie durften eine Kopie von dem Buch machen. Die Kopie durften sie an die Bibliothek schicken, wo dieser Wissenschaftler ansässig war. Der Wissenschaftler durfte in die Bibliothek gehen, sich eine Kopie von der Kopie machen und die Gastbibliothek musste dann die Originalkopie an die Staatsbibliothek schicken. Es wäre nicht so gewesen, wenn er schwerbehindert gewesen wäre. Deshalb fragen halt viele Bibliothekarin oder Bibliothekarin, wenn sie angerufen werden und so eine Anfrage kriegen, sind sie schwerbehindert? Und wenn ja, dann erleichtert das vieles. Es gibt auch einen internationalen Vertrag, der mit Vielhauen und Stechen ausgehandelt wurde und der besagt, dass blinden Organisationen unter sehr bestimmten Umständen Audiobooks oder irgendwie von blinden Lesegeräten lesbare E-Books blinden zur Verfügung stellen dürfen. Das erfordert natürlich eine Umgehung von Kopierschutz. Gegen dieses internationale Abkommen haben Verlage wirklich aufs übelste Lobbyismus betrieben. Und dieser Vertrag ist auch nach wie vor nicht ratifiziert, weil sich die EU und die Mitgliedstaaten nicht darauf einigen können, wer für diese Ratifizierung zuständig ist. Das heißt, es sind nach wie vor unter 5% aller E-Books für blinde Lesbar. Obwohl die dafür bezahlen wollen würden, wenn sie es könnten. Es geht halt nicht. Der Markt ist nicht da.
Und denen geht es um die Sorge, dass die dann diese einmal vom DRM befreiten Bücher nehmen?
Da könnte ja jeder kommen. Also die könnten ja ins Internet gestellt werden.
Ich finde das bemerkenswert, das ist nicht das richtige, aber bewundernswert, sich mit so einem Wahnsinn überhaupt auseinanderzusetzen. Macht dir das eigentlich Spaß?
Ja, das macht mir großen Spaß. Ich war jetzt vor kurzem in den USA auf einer Fact-Finding-Mission, so nennt sich das, wo ich rausfinde, wie das mit dem Urheberrecht in anderen Ländern ist. Da habe ich jemanden getroffen von der IFF, der hatte sich einen Teil der amerikanischen Verfassung tätowiert, der eine gewisse Einschränkung des Urheberrechts bedeutet. Es gibt so einen kleinen Kreis von Urheberrechts-Nerds, die das mit großem Engagement verfolgen. Die besten Erfahrungen habe ich letztendlich im akademischen Bereich gemacht, weil die Juristen, die sich mit dem Urheberrecht beschäftigen, die wissen das alles schon, dass das absurd und verrückt ist. Es überrascht die Politik immer, wenn sich herausstellt, dass die rechtswissenschaftlichen Institute, die am Urheberrecht arbeiten, alle mit der Pirate in einer Meinung sind. Aber deren Konferenzen sind hochinteressant und ich habe da sehr viel Spaß dran.
Also betratzt das sozusagen als sportliche Herausforderung?
Es ist ein riesiges Strategiespiel in gewisser Weise. Also parlamentarische Arbeit ohnehin. Und ich kann das nur jedem empfehlen. Ich glaube, wir haben sehr viel zu wenige Leute letzten Endes, die irgendwie von außen in die Politik reinkommen und versuchen in diesem System mitzuspielen und Sachen zu verändern. Letzten Endes sind die Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten einer einzelnen Abgeordneten enorm und es gibt viel zu wenige Leute, die das versuchen.
Tja, also bevor wir da noch mehr Nazis reinwählen ins Europaparlament, können wir ja vielleicht noch ein paar unterstützte Personen nachwählen lassen. Haben wir nicht immer so im Griff. Für deine Ausführung.
Bin nicht entlassen.
Die Frage erübrigt sich, aber du würdest es weiter, wirst du da weiter bleiben wollen?
Also für mich hängt es ein bisschen davon ab, ob wir in vier Jahren bei der nächsten Wahl mit dieser Reform fertig sind. Also ich habe keine Lust, irgendwie eine halbfertige Reform dann liegen zu lassen, wo das nächste Parlament das Gegenteil tut. Ich will aber gleichzeitig auch nicht mein gesamtes Leben in diesem Parlament verbringen. Also es ist schon merkwürdig. Man stellt nach einer Weile fest, dass diese Ansüge unglaublich merkwürdig bequem sind und man auch irgendwie nichts Privates mehr twittert und so. Und ich glaube, irgendwann wird man von diesem System aufgefressen. Also irgendwie eine zweite Amtszeit würde ich vielleicht anstreben, wenn es notwendig ist, um diese Urheberrechtsreform fertig zu machen.
Das ist die beste Antwort auf diese Frage, die ich je gehört habe.
So, das ist der erste Block. Ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt schon geschafft halbwegs zu überziehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, hatten wir irgendetwas versprochen? Hat mir irgendjemand irgendetwas versprochen?
Ich weiß nicht, sind die anderen noch da?
Würdest du überhaupt jemanden irgendwie was versprochen haben?
Seit wann bist du hier?
Neun.
Also drei Stunden erst.
Die Technik ist schon leicht überarbeitet. Aber wir laden jetzt gleich mal nach, hier für unseren zweiten und letzten Block, wo wir nämlich auch noch mal ein bisschen nachhaken wollen. Und wir werden das auch nachher noch mal so ein bisschen dazu äußern, wer diese Sendung eigentlich regelmäßig unterstützt. Aber einer davon ist auf jeden Fall Andre Meister. Und der wird jetzt hier gleich mit Mikrofon ausgestattet und wird zu uns stoßen. Wer Logbuch Netzpolitik regelmäßig verfolgt, wird wissen, dass Andre schon häufiger zu Gast war und hier immer wieder mit kompetenten Einblicken uns aus der Bredouille hilft. Andre ist einer der Helden des Camps.
Habe ich auf Spiegel online gelesen.
Ach so steht das da?
Ja. Echt? Wie ein Held. Wie ein Held.
Ok, könntet ihr bitte auch noch einen Cape anlegen?
Ich hätte hier einen Cape für dich Andre.
Willst du das haben?
Ne, das geht gar nicht mehr mit dem Mikro.
Na los komm, du bist hier unsere Diskokugel.
Für diejenigen, die die Sendung öfter hören, Andre war in der letzten Sendung zusammen mit Markus Becke da zu Gast. Frischer, nicht mehr des Landesverrats beschuldigter Journalist. Wie fühlt es sich an?
Nicht mehr Landesverräter zu sein?
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht, auch nicht anders als vorher. Ist schon ganz in Ordnung, nicht mehr irgendwie Markus Mutter, nachdem sie Videotext gelesen hat, am Telefon zu haben. Ich habe gehört, du kommst lebenslänglich in den Knast. Aber wir haben uns sehr gefreut, dass die Ermittlungen eingestellt sind. Wir hatten das aber früher oder später auch erwartet, denn es war ziemlich an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Insofern, dass die Juristen, die uns... Hier fehlt übrigens was, Cebas.
Cebas, genau, du hast deine Aufgabe nicht erfüllt.
Die Juristen, mit denen wir gesprochen haben, die haben sowieso gesagt, dass wir da irgendwann früher oder später tatsächlich angeklagt werden. Das halten die für wenig wahrscheinlich. Dass wir verurteilt werden, noch weniger wahrscheinlich. Aber dass jetzt endlich den Brief schwarzerweiß zu haben, dass es eingestellt ist, schon ganz gut. Rechtzeitig vorm Camp, vielen Dank.
Tim kriegt was?
Nein, eigentlich ist das ja so.
Was?
Wir kriegen zwei Bier und wir kriegen keins?
Hat zufällig noch jemand ein Bier?
Ich will auch noch ein Bier.
Das hab ich doch gesagt, Sebas.
Dann muss ich jetzt hier als trauriger Panda ohne Bier sitzen. Was?
Ach nee, du darfst zuerst was.
Geh mal her.
Guten Morgen.
Ja, guten Morgen. Schön, dass du zu uns gestoßen bist.
Ich musste so lange warten mit Bier trinken.
Jetzt kommt noch ein drittes Bier.
Ja, voll.
Triss das.
Danke dir. Ich trinke das gar nicht. Das trinke ich auch noch. Also, Andre ist aus dem... Vielen Dank. Das hast du doch super gemacht. Der Grund, warum Andre eigentlich hier ist, er hat heute schon lange mit Markus darüber gesprochen. Wir wollen über die Landesverräter-Sache gar nicht so lange sprechen, weil die Landesverratssache hat Andre nämlich sehr geärgert. Weil da ein Bericht bei netzpolitik.org völlig untergegangen ist, dem du gerne noch Aufmerksamkeit gegeben hättest.
Ja, das ist so wie die Landesverratsstory, die ist ja auch eigentlich untergegangen, weil eine Stunde, nachdem wir das gepostet hatten, damals im April, hat der Justizminister sich entschlossen, eine Vorratsartenspeicherung anzukündigen. Und dann waren wir erstmal damit beschäftigt. Und die Medienlandschaft auch. Und dieses Verfassungsschutzpapier, das wir da gelegt haben, hat eigentlich keines auch interessiert. Bis zum Streisand vor ein paar Wochen. Und an dem Donnerstag vor zwei Wochen, als dieser Landesverrat Vorwurfbrief ins Haus flatterte, habe ich auch gedacht, da hat Markus gesagt, hier, blog mal, das ist wichtig. Und er ist so, ja, gleich, gleich muss ich erstmal dieses eine Ding hier zu Ende machen. Und habe erstmal Cyber gemacht. Und wie heißt das Ding überhaupt? Cyber-Leitlinie der Bundeswehr veröffentlicht. Soll ich es einfach monologisieren und eine halbe Stunde runterraten, was das total steht?
Nee, nee, nee, ich kann auch zwischendurch Fragen stellen.
Ich auch. Ich habe übrigens im Internet nachgeguckt. Cyber kommt von kurz nach dem Krieg, wurde aber natürlich von William Gibson und Neuromancer sehr gepusht. Also hast recht gehabt mit dem Science-Fiction Autoren. Ich habe vor kurzem in Hackers wieder geguckt. Deswegen heißt ja der eine Computer von der Evil Corp. da ja auch The Gibson. Als Hommage an William Gibson wegen Cyber.
Cyber-Light-Linie.
Das ist so ein Papier vom Bundeswehr- und v.a. Verteidigungsministerium, unserer altbekannten Ursula von der Leyen, mit der wir netzpolitisch ja schon den einen oder anderen Kampf ausgefochten haben. Und ja, da steht im Endeffekt drin, die Bundeswehr macht jetzt auch Cyberwar. Das sind so 20 Seiten, nur für den Dienst gebrauchen, mit einer neuen Klassifizierungsstufe, die ich vorher noch nie gesehen habe, nur für Deutsche. Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt Landesverrat war oder so, das zu posten. Steht online auf netzpolitik.org, in Volltext, wie immer.
Nur Deutschen zur Kenntnis.
Nur Deutschen zur Kenntnis, genau.
Also, die nicht-Deutschen im Publikum und im Internet. Julia, was machen wir jetzt mit denen? Können wir die Geo blocken?
Und da steht im Endeffekt drin, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt eben auch Cyberwarmen machen will. Ist grad hip. Da steht irgendwie, auf 20 Seiten haben die es geschafft, ganze 137 Mal das Wort Cyber zu verwenden. Das war schon fast so geil wie das Intro hier. Aber das ist offizieller Sprachgebrauch in der Regierung, in der Bundeswehr, in allen möglichen Stellen.
Was meinen die denn damit? Ist jetzt, also, was heißt das? Heißt das Internet?
Ja, tatsächlich ist irgendwo in der Fußnote auch ein Versuch einer Definition. Müss ich jetzt selber nochmal nachgucken. Ich glaube, das bedeutet so ungefähr wie, ja, wir meinen Internet, wir meinen aber auch alle anderen technischen Systeme und Netzwerke, die nicht unmittelbar am Internet hängen, wie Computer-Netzwerke, gegnerische Militärs oder sowas.
Also meinen sie Computer?
Nein, weil es muss auch kommunizieren können.
Computer-Netzwerke.
Ach, was weiß ich denn, ich hab's mir auch nicht ausgedacht. Auf jeden Fall steht da drin, die wollen jetzt irgendwie, die Bundeswehr kann ja Krieg führen in Land, Wasser, Luft, Weltraum, können sie auch. Und jetzt haben sie auch noch den Cyber-Raum, da wollen sie jetzt auch Krieg führen. In der sogenannten, die nennen das offiziell den Kampf in der fünften Dimension. Das hab ich mir nicht ausgedacht, das ist sehr in Sprache gebraucht.
Land, Wasser, Luft, Weltraum, Cyber.
Oh man.
In der fünften Dimension. Und sie sprechen dann von Wirkmöglichkeiten. Ja das ist geil, das gibt's aber auch schon lange.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch hat denn gedient?
Wer hat gedient?
Hat ja einer gedient. Und was sind Wirkmittel?
Wirkmittel?
Das ist doch Waffen oder nicht? Genau, Cyber-Waffen.
Also ich hab zwar nicht gedient, aber Wirkmittel ist doch ganz klar. Man muss halt nur sehr auf den Feind einwirken, dann wird er schon nachgeben. Okay, also sie brauchen jetzt Wirkmittel für den Cyber-Raum. Mich schmerzt das.
Digitale Waffen.
Mir tut es weh, wenn ich dieses Wort benutze. Mir tut es weh. Geht's euch das nicht ausu? Ich krieg das nicht über die Lippen. Cyber. Doch, ich krieg's über die Lippen, aber ich krieg's nicht durch den Kopf.
Muss ich das aufmachen?
Nee, ich mach mein Bier selber.
Wir haben da jetzt viel drüber gelacht und ich hab auch, wir fielen da auch anfangs eigentlich nur Witze zu einer, aber wenn man sich mal darüber Gedanken macht, was irgendwie dieses Internet für die Menschheit bedeutet, für unser Zusammenleben bedeutet und was Computer für uns bedeuten, nicht nur als jetzt wir, als diejenigen, die hier sitzen und schönen Computer und so, sondern auch für unsere Gesellschaft und wie viel von diesen Rechensystemen abhängt und dass das Militär das jetzt als etwas sieht, was gleichbedeutend mit Land, Luft, See und Weltraum ist, indem man beabsichtigt zu operieren, dann kann man sich auch vorstellen, in welcher Form und in welchem Ausmaß die da wirken. Wenn man sich mal anschaut, was die irgendwie bauen für das Land, für Fahrzeuge und für Waffen, um das zu zerstören, See ähnlich, die See lassen sie in der Regel heile, die vergiften sie nur, Weltraum okay, ist die Bundeswehr bisher noch nicht aufgefallen. Wenn sie jetzt irgendwie diese Konzepte auf den Cyber-Raum ausweiten und sich darüber Gedanken machen, Fähigkeiten und Ressourcen aufzuwenden, um koordinierte Maßnahmen zur Beeinträchtigung vorzunehmen, zur Beeinträchtigung von fremden Informations- und Kommunikationssystemen, also wie der darin verarbeiteten Informationen, dann kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, was das für eine Zukunft ist, die sie sich vorstellen. Und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was dem entgegenzusetzen ist, also wie man die daran hindern soll. Das habe ich, also wir haben ja auch persönlich da mal kurz drüber gesprochen. Ich weiß ja, also ich bin ganz tatsächlich, bin ich mir nicht darüber im Klaren, ich habe eigentlich als Kind meiner Mutter schon die Frage gestellt, ey, warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, als Land, wir machen bei dem Krieg, wir machen bei diesem ganzen Militärkram nicht mit und wir setzen einfach darauf, dass wer auch immer uns angreift, auf jeden Fall im Unrecht ist. Wir haben einfach kein Militär. Und meine Mutter hat mir dann gesagt, naja, das Risiko wäre, dass sie dann halt tatsächlich kommen und dann gibt es das Land nicht mehr. Aber wir hätten Recht gehabt. Aber jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie steht jetzt die Bundeswehr da, wenn sie, also.
Du meinst, wenn sie kein Cyber-Wirkmittel hätte.
Sie wollen natürlich die Cyber-Atomen bauen, das ist klar. Ja, natürlich.
Die Cyber-Atombombe.
Ja, den On-Off-Scheiter. Also ich frage mich halt, warum ist das, also ich weiß auch, dass es ein Leak war oder ein Thema war, was dir sehr am Herzen liegt.
Jana, du hast jetzt irgendwie fünf Punkte aufgemacht. Ich pick mir mal zwei raus, die mir gefallen. Politiker, haben wir ja gerade bei Julia gelernt. Also ganz so neu ist das jetzt dann auch nicht. Es gibt da diesen urban myth, dass das Internet irgendwie von den Militärs erfunden wurde. Da kann, weiß ich nicht, Onkel Tim was vom Cyberwar erzählen, wie das wirklich war, weil laut ihm war das ja eher Forschung, nicht Militär. Aber wir haben ja gerade durch Snowden gelernt, im Endeffekt, die NSA ist ja auch der Militärgeheimdienst. Das ist ja nicht irgendwie ein Auslandsgeheimdienst, das ist der Militärgeheimdienst der USA. Und die Five Eyes und die NSA, die nutzen das Internet tatsächlich, um zu herrschen und Macht durchzusetzen mit so einem Tusch wie Treasure Map. Oder auch, wir haben ja irgendwie jahrelang über jede einzelne Enthüllung geredet, um tatsächlich allen anderen voraus zu sein. Und von dem Militärgeheimdienst natürlich auch zuallererst für militärische Fähigkeiten. Dass das genutzt wird, sollte uns jetzt so nicht überraschen. Aber, dass die Bundeswehr das natürlich macht, ist für uns natürlich noch mal relevanter, einsinerseits, weil es greifbarer ist, weil wir hier auch einfacher deutsche Politik und Öffentlichkeit bestimmen können, als wir das hier für die US-Öffentlichkeit könnten. Und dann haben wir natürlich noch geschichtliche Eigenarten, zum Beispiel, dass die Bundeswehr irgendwie keine Angriffskriege durchführen darf, dass sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht im Inland eingesetzt werden darf, und dass sie irgendwie nur mit einem Parlamentsbeschluss und eigentlich auch nur unter internationalem Mandat eingesetzt werden darf. Und alle diese Fragen verschwimmen halt, wenn man irgendwie das Internet zum Kriegsschauplatz erklärt und jetzt eine Box zonen und aufmachen, woher wissen die, ob das im In- oder im Ausland ist? Also ich habe dann auch nicht mehr geschrieben Bundeswehr-Einsatz im Inneren oder im Ausland, sondern Bundeswehr-Einsatz im Internet.
Vielleicht wäre mal Geoblocking auch für was gut.
Da tun sich so viele Fragen auf.
Attribution.
Wir haben es ja irgendwie beim Cyber-Cyber-Bundestag mal wieder vor Augen geführt bekommen. Wenn irgendwo eine Malware sitzt, dann kannst du zwar ein paar Hinweise rausziehen, die Anschein erwecken, wo etwas herstammen könnte. Du kannst das aber nie hundertprozentig sicher sagen. Was ist jetzt, wenn irgendwie die, die sprechen da von kritischer Infrastruktur oder so, nehmen wir an, irgendeine Börse wird aufgemacht, abgeschossen, wie das teilweise in, was hatten wir das, Estland und Georgien auch schon hatten. Da steht dann in der Zeitung schnell, das waren die Russen. Aber wie will man das nachweisen? Und vor allem reicht das nur, dass es geopolitisch, so Kibono-mäßig gerade den Russen passen würde und dass man irgendwie ein paar russische Fragmente und ein paar russische IPs findet. Reicht das für eine Kriegserklärung gegen ein anderes Land? Das sind so Fragen, die so völlig neu sind in diesem Zusammenhang. Weil früher war es ziemlich easy, woher geschossen wurde, festzustellen, auf welchem Territorium das war. Das geht heute nicht mehr. Das schreiben die ja darin auch so explizit, dass sie nie genau sicher sein können, wo was herkommt. Aber dann auf dieser Basis irgendwie, tatsächlich steht ja auch drin, wenn die uns im Cyber-Raum angreifen, ja dann schicken wir halt auch Flugzeuge. Und Panzer zurück. Völlig gaga. Und da gibt es halt bisher überhaupt keine öffentliche Diskussion darüber, wie wir damit umgehen. Deswegen finde ich es ja mal wieder so wichtig, die Diskussion zu führen. Eben auch anhand von Originaldokumenten. Und eben nicht auch nur in einem so kleinen Bubble auf dem Kongress mit den üblichen Nerds, die sich seit Jahren über sowas Gedanken machen. Sondern eben auch Gesamtgesellschaft liegt. Weil das ist halt größer. Da gibt es irgendwie auch ein Posting mit Verteidigungshaushalt. Posten ist der zweitgrößte Haushaltsposten von den gesamten deutschen Steuerausgaben nach Arbeits- und Soziales. Da gehen immense Summen rein, was in unseren Namen dargestellt wird. Und ich würde schon gerne mitreden, nicht nur aus Eigennutz.
Du hast gerade noch etwas Interessantes gesagt, Krieg erklären. Macht Deutschland das? Ich dachte, wir haben doch immer nur bewaffneter Konflikt.
Afghanistan-Einsatz ist ein Kriegseinsatz, das ist ein Kampfeinsatz. Ja, das wird dann geframt als Brunnenbohren mit irgendwie Bewaffnung und Schutz, als Friedensmission, auch UNO-Friedensmission oder so. Aber das ist ein Kampfeinsatz, wenn man das jetzt, diesen Neusprech von Friedenspanzern übernimmt, das ist völlig irrelevant, auch für juristische Einschätzungen, ob das jetzt ein Kriegseinsatz ist oder nicht. Auch Bundeswehreinsatz überhaupt geht nicht im Inneren. Bundeswehreinsatz in externen Ländern mit Bewaffnung, wie es gerade, keine Ahnung, in der Türkei, in der ganzen Syrien und in einigen anderen Einsatzländern, Afghanistan ja noch ist, auch Balkan immer noch, das sind Kriegseinsätze, bewaffnete Kriegseinsätze.
Denen steht aber immer ein Parlamentsbeschluss entgegen.
Genau, der Deutsche Bundestag muss das beschließen, was auch eine wieder der Kernfrage von dem Cyber-Angriff ist, was es jetzt, wenn irgendeine Kiste geohnt wird und die wollen zurückschlagen, überhaupt wo ist die Grenze von Angriff und Verteidigung? Die sprechen dann in dem Papier davon, dass die Bundeswehr so ähnlich wie das dieses System Treasure Map der NSA ist. Wer von euch kennt Treasure Map? Oh, das sind wenige. Okay, also was im Endeffekt die NSA macht, wurde auch vom Spiegel mit auseinandergenommen mit ein paar Folien, ist eben so eine Art Schatzkarte vom Internet und zwar von irgendwie permanent alle Geräte, die im Netz sind, scannen, alle Autonomensysteme, alle Endgeräte, alle Kennungen, alle IP-Adressen, MAC-Adressen und so und so eine permanente Zuordnbarkeit von welchen Geräten gibt es, welche Netzwerke gibt es, wie viel Traffic geht da hin und her, welche Geräte werden welchen Nationalitäten oder sogar Personen oder Institutionen zugeordnet und dann eben auch einen weiteren Schritt, welche Services fahren da drauf und welche Vulnerabilities gibt es eventuell, welche Versionen fahren darauf und so und das ist eben die Bundeswehr als Cyber-Lagebild. Man braucht ja irgendwie erstmal ein Lagebild, wenn man irgendwie Kampfeinsatz macht. Die nennen das Cyber-Lagebild und die wollen halt permanent irgendwie so eine Karte von allen, weiß ich nicht, IPv4s und MAC-Adressen haben und was da drauf für Services fahren, damit sie wissen, was sie eventuell, wenn sie denn wollen, jetzt irgendwie einen Exploit drauf abfeuern. Du lachst, das ist richtig da drin, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Es ist dann auf dem Leuchttisch im Holodeck.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, genau.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, ich frage mich, man kann jetzt über die Bundeswehr denken, wie man will, aber sie ist ja grundsätzlich sozusagen als Verteidigungskonzept angelegt. Ob sie das jetzt sozusagen mit ihren einzelnen Missionen auch immer tut, da am Hindukusch und sonst wo, das lasse ich jetzt mal offen, aber das ist sozusagen die Ausrichtung. Wenn man sich jetzt so mal versucht, es ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber ich versuche mich so in deren Lage zu versetzen, und sie sehen sozusagen eine Bedrohung von außen, dann ist das ja quasi auch ein nachvollziehbarer Wunsch, sozusagen auch solche externen Bedrohungen, von denen sie sicherlich überzeugt sind, dass sie existieren, und die ja auch da sind, sich zumindest ein Lagebild machen zu können.
Also ich frage mich noch, welche Bedrohung da ist. Also wer greift denn gerade die Bundesrepublik oder ihre Grenzen an?
Naja, man greift halt sozusagen die Firmen, die Wirtschaft, das Geld an.
Ja, aber dazu ist der Bundeswehr nicht zuständig. Wir haben ein BSE, das genau dafür zuständig ist, oder zumindest sein sollte. Das ist auch noch so ein Ding. Da gibt es ein immenses Kompetenzgerangel. Jeder will jetzt Cyber machen an Bundesbehörden. Wir haben ja vor irgendwie zwei Tage, ehe die erste Meldung kam, zu unserem Landesverratsfuhr, dass der Verfassungsschutzchef uns anzeigt, wurde ja das neue Verfassungsschutzgesetz im Bundestag beschlossen. Da steht unter anderem drin, da wird ein Haufen Sachen neu geregelt, da steht unter anderem drin, dass der BND bei seinen Glasfaserabschnoschelaktionen jetzt nicht mehr nur nach Terror, organisierter Kriminalität, Drogen, Migration, Geldfälschung, das sind, glaube ich, die üblichen Gründe, weswegen sie das machen dürfen, sondern jetzt dürfen sie auch nach Cyber suchen. Das heißt, sie sitzen am Dezix, schnoscheln den ab und filtern da jetzt irgendwie Zero Days raus, oder was? Das ist jetzt offiziell erlaubt, das machen die, dafür haben die Millionen Kohle neue Technik und Ressourcen und werfen da neue Selektoren raus. Hat die Öffentlichkeit so gut wie nicht interessiert.
Sie suchen nach Cyber?
Die suchen nach Cyber. Der BND macht jetzt offiziell Cyber-Abwehr in seinen Abschnuschl-Aktionen und die suchen da halt Cyber-Angriffe auf Deutschland auf, kritische Infrastruktur, wie es immer so schön heißt oder so. Gibt aber auch noch andere, es gibt eben das BSI, ist zuständig, das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, auch als Oberbehörde, auch im, äh, nee, doch im Ministerium, ist auch zuständig für den Schutz von Infrastruktur, von öffentlichen Institutionen, Wirtschaft und Privatpersonen. Die haben nun aber keinen Zugang zu den Glasfasern am Dezix, sondern die sind eher so Defens, wie man das eigentlich machen sollte, bis auf das sie am Staatsfreund mitarbeiten und so, aber ich schenke ihnen mal kurz keine Beachtung. Die sind eigentlich dafür zuständig, Gerätennetzwerke sicherer zu machen. Dann gibt es noch das sogenannte Cyber-Abwehrzentrum, irgendwie so ein gemeinsames Zentrum von allen Behörden, die irgendwas damit zu tun haben, also BKA, LKA, Verfassungsschutz vom Bund, Verfassungsschutz von Ländern, MAD, Militärischer Abschüttendienst, BND, BSI und wen es da noch so alles gibt. Die machen auch Cyber-Abwehr im Cyber-Abwehrzentrum. Sagt dann der Bundesrechnungshof, also das Verfassungsschutz macht das, der BND macht das, das BSI macht das und das Cyber-Abwehrzentrum macht das auch. Ist ein bisschen Steuerverschwendung. Wir sollten das einstampfen und dass nur eine Institution das macht, statt dass der Arbeit immer wieder gemacht wird, haben die schon vor drei Jahren gesagt. Auf das Gutachten warte ich immer noch. Wenn das irgendjemand hat, mal an unsere E-Mail schicken. Und dass die Bundeswehr oder die BND die richtigen Akteure wären, deutsche IT-Infrastruktur für äußeren Angriffen zu schützen, das kann man durchaus diskutieren und anders sehen, weil wir haben nämlich das BSI, das genau dafür zuständig ist. Und die Bundeswehr ist eine fucking Armee, die führt einen Krieg. Ob die jetzt tatsächlich auch in ihrem Mindset, dass sie irgendwie durch den Schlamm robben und Panzer fahren, üben, morgens geweckt werden und gedrückt werden, die richtigen sind, deutsche kritische Infrastruktur aus dem Netz zu befürchten, ich habe da so meine Zweifel. Zert gibt es auch noch. Ich glaube, der Klub könnte das besser als die Bundeswehr.
Und in dem Dokument, was ihr ja berichtet habt, ist ja von offensiven Cyber-Fähigkeiten die Rede. Das klingt jetzt auch nicht gerade unbedingt nach Rückzug.
Genau, das ist das nächste.
Ich finde es ziemlich viel mehr. Wie muss ich mir das denn vorstellen? Deswegen hatte ich gerade danach gefragt, du brauchst ja einen Parlamentsbeschluss. Also wollen die jetzt irgendwie Hacker mit A13 einstellen und sie müssen dann auf einen Parlamentsbeschluss warten, um Enter zu drücken? Oder wie stellen die sich jetzt die Kriegsführung vor?
Das möchte ich auch gerne im Detail noch wissen. Ich glaube, ein paar Punkte zu wissen, also gerade hatte ich ja eben angefangen, zum Beispiel mit dem Cyber-Lagebild. Ist das Defense, ist das Offense, wenn du irgendwie permanent ein Post-Scan über das ganze Internet machst und irgendwie eine Database von Vulnerabilities hast, brauchst du dafür, ist das ein Bundeswehreinsatz im Internet oder nicht? Brauchst du da einen Parlamentsbeschluss? Und dann auch darf die Bundeswehr überhaupt, zum Beispiel, da steht ja so da drin, TK-Infrastruktur, mit denen potenzielle Gegner kommunizieren, um die mal für eine Weile auszuschalten oder zu übernehmen oder zu verändern. Wie ziehst du da die Grenze? Wirst du jetzt mal angenommen der BRD Würde angegriffen? Kannst du dann irgendwie ein Mobilfunknetz von einem Land ausschalten, das zivil genutzt wird? Ist das ein legitimer Einsatz der Bundeswehr? Dürfen die das? Das sind viele Fragen offen und auch bei jedem Einsatz. Was ist überhaupt eine Einsatzschwelle? Was ist ein Einsatz? Nur, dass du jetzt die Wohlen gescannt hast, den Exploit dafür kaufst und baust, und die Leute da hast, die dann nur noch Enter drücken müssen. Ist das schon ein Einsatz? Oder ist dann der Enterdruck das, was wir vorher erst noch im Bundestag beschließen müssen? Das sind genau die Fragen, die wir jetzt diskutieren müssen. Ehe dieser Einsatz soweit ist. Aber das hat irgendwie von der Leine im April mal mir nichts unterschrieben. Das ist seitdem in Kraft. Aber erfahren haben wir davon erst durch den Spiegel drei Wochen vor uns. Und jetzt eben, dass wir dieses Ding da in Volltext draufgesetzt haben. Insofern, die Fragen müssen dringend diskutiert werden. Ehe es passiert, ist aber andersrum. Das Parlament wurde auch noch nicht informiert darüber.
Ich denke, auf eine Frage haben wir auf jeden Fall die Antwort. Und das ist, arbeitet bitte nicht für diese Leute.
Also tatsächlich, die haben, weiß nicht, ob ihr jetzt Schluss machen wollt, weil ihr rausgekickt werdet oder so. Tatsächlich gab es schon 2009 Berichte, dass die Bundeswehr 76 Hacker in Uniform hat. Ich glaube, das ist seitdem nicht weniger geworden, sondern eher mehr. Die sind, weiß ich nicht, die würden wahrscheinlich auch nur liebend gern auf dem Kongress rekrutieren oder auf so einem Camp und hier Leute erfischen bei anderen Veranstaltungen, die jetzt so um die Jahreszeit laufen in anderen Staaten, da ist das auch ziemlich offen. Hier zum Glück ist die Kultur ja eine andere. Aber die sagen nicht nur, dass sie irgendwie gerne Hacker in Uniform hätten, also Leute, die an der Bundeswehr-Uni gehen und sich dort irgendeine technische Ausbildung machen, sondern die sagen auch ganz explizit, wir haben nicht genug Kräfte. Und im Fall eines Falles kann es natürlich sein, dass wir in der freien Wirtschaft gucken müssen. Und dann sind wir wieder bei den üblichen Partnerfirmen wie CSC und üblichen Zuliefererfirmen. Dann haben wir ja gerade die Staatstreuerner-Buden. Die werden sie bestimmt auch anfragen, obwohl sie auch Eigenentwicklungen fahren wollen. Da ist die Grenze nicht ganz so einfach, wie dass man tatsächlich gezogen wird und in Uniform angesetzt wird. Einen Schritt weiter denken als einfach nur einen coolen Exploit zu bauen, sondern auch immerhin zu hinterfragen, für wen arbeitet man da gerade und wer kauft das im Endeffekt und setzt das wofür ein. Das ist ja eine Club-Diskussion schon seit langer Zeit. Und da ist der Club ja glücklicherweise auch recht erfolgreich im Vergleich zu anderen Hacker-Organisationen der Welt.
So eine Leute heißen jetzt Cyber-Söldner.
Cyber-Söldner, ich habe die Küberkrieger genannt.
Wir sollten zum Ende kommen.
Ja, wir sollten zum Ende kommen. Wir haben schon maßlos überzogen, Andre. Einen Satz noch zum Camp? Oder zwei?
Ich glaube, ich habe einen Sonnenbrand. Ich muss morgen mal baden gehen und ich freue mich endlich wieder Bier trinken zu können. Ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen zurückhalten und warten, damit ich nicht zu viel rumlalle auf der Bühne.
Ja, also das ist Spaß.
Camp ist gut, immer. Camp ist das spannendeste Event so aus dem Clubumfeld. Es sind viel zu viele Leute da, die ich wieder alle nicht dazu kommen, mit allen möglichen mal ein Bier zu trinken und zu quatschen. Aber so ist das. Besser so als andersrum.
So, und wir haben auch noch eine kleine Überraschung.
Wir haben eine Überraschung, ja.
Genau, wir haben eine Überraschung.
Das ist eine Überraschung für euch von...
Die, die durchgehalten haben.
Genau, für die, die durchgehalten haben, gibt es eine Überraschung von Fiona, Pepe und mir. Und die befindet sich unter eurem Sitz.
Da müsst ihr jetzt mal unter euren Sitz greifen.
Oh, die kleben aber zu fest.
Kaugummi, ne?
Genau, unter dem Sitz ist Kaugummi.
Genau, gibt es jetzt noch coole Logbuch Netzpolitik-Aufkleber für euch. Und Collect All Seven. Ihr könnt dann schon mal anfangen zu tauschen.
Genau, es gibt sieben verschiedene Motive.
Ihr dürft jetzt sozusagen die unbesetzten Sitze dann auch gleich noch plündern, damit die nicht wieder zum Verleihern mit zurückgehen. Und, ja, wir können doch nochmal...
Jetzt ist Unruhe. Jetzt ist genau die Unruhe, die du meintest.
Jetzt ist die Unruhe da, die ich meinte, aber wir...
Soler, ich komme da jetzt aber nicht davon. Was ist denn deine zwei Sätze zum Camp?
Meine zwei Sätze zum Camp, das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, aber ich finde dieses Camp außerordentlich gelungen. Und ich freue mich vor allem immer wieder, wenn ich feststellen darf, dass diese Club-Veranstaltungen, auch wenn sie auf einmal wachsen und das Camp so zum letzten Mal, ist irgendwie mal locker 40 Prozent mehr, trotzdem irgendwie immer noch sehr harmonisch skalieren. Und dass man irgendwie am Ende eigentlich immer wieder feststellt, dass das irgendwie immer noch dieselbe Veranstaltung ist, obwohl sie irgendwie wächst. Und gegeben, dass wir dann auch passende Locations dafür finden, könnte das wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft wieder funktionieren. Okay, Linus ist durch, deswegen sage ich vielen Dank Andre, vielen Dank Julia, vielen Dank hier alle zum Zuhören, vielen Dank an alle, die unser Projekt, unseren Podcast unterstützt haben, gehört haben, weiter erzählt haben und so weiter. Und jetzt hier bis zum Schluss da geblieben sind, wir trinken jetzt alle noch zusammen ein Bier und ich sag Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Spezielles Danke an Arne, Fiona, Florian, Pepo, Thomas Lohninger, netzpolitik.org, alle Spender, Tippgeber, Lika, Weiterzähler und die, die euch die tausend Sticker unter diese Stühle geklebt haben, ihr müsst ja auch nochmal einladen.